[Music]
this is a song sung by a brown thrasher
but that's just one of the thousand or
more that it knows and it's not the only
avian virtuoso a wood thrush can sing
two pitches at once a Mockingbird can
match the sounds around it including car
alarms and the Australian superb
Lyrebird has an incredible elaborate
song and dance ritual these are just a
few of the four thousand species of
songbirds most birds produce short
simple calls but songbirds also have a
repertoire of complex vocal patterns
that help them attract mates defend a
territory and strengthen their social
bonds each song bird species has its own
distinct song patterns some with
characteristic regional dialects
experienced listeners can even
distinguish individual birds by their
unique songs so how do birds learn these
songs in the first place how do they
know to mimic the songs of their own
species are they born knowing how to
sing a lot of what scientists know about
birdsong comes from studying zebra
finches a baby male zebra finch
typically learns to sing from its father
or other males starting while it's still
a fledgling in the nest first comes a
sensory learning phase when the baby
finch hears the songs sung around it and
commits them to memory the bird starts
to vocalize during the motor learning
phase practicing until it can match the
song it memorized as the bird learns
hearing the tutors song over and over
again is helpful up to a point if he
hears it too many times the imitation
degrades and the source matters if the
song is played through a loudspeaker he
can't pick it up as easily but hide the
same loudspeaker inside a toy painted to
look like a zebra finch
his learning improves what if the baby
never here's another zebra finches song
interestingly enough it'll sing anyway
isolated finches still produce what are
called innate or isolate songs a
specific tune might be taught but the
instinct to sing seems to be hardwired
into a songbirds brain innate songs
sound different from the cultured songs
learned from other finches at first if
isolate zebra finches start a new colony
the young birds pick up the isolate song
from their parents but the song changes
from generation to generation and after
a few iterations the melody actually
starts to resemble the cultured songs
sung by zebra finches in the wild
something about the learning process
must be hardwired to drawing the birds
towards the same song patterns again and
again this means that basic information
about the zebra finch song must be
stored somewhere in its genome imprinted
there by millions of years of evolution
at first this might seem odd as we
usually think of genetic code as a
source of biochemical or physical traits
not something like a behavior or action
but the two aren't fundamentally
different we can connect genomes to
behavior through brain circuitry the
connection is noisy and quite complex it
doesn't simply map single genes to
single behaviors but it exists genomes
contain codes for proteins that guide
brain development such as molecules that
guide the pathways of developing axons
shaping distinct circuits Birds brains
have so-called song circuits that are
active when the birds sing these
circuits also respond to the song of a
bird's own species more strongly than to
other species songs so the theory is
that a bird's genes guide development of
brain circuits that relate to singing
and the ability to learn songs then
exposure to songs shapes those neural
circuits to produce the songs that are
typical to that species
genetically encoded or innate behaviors
aren't unique to songbirds they're
widespread in the animal kingdom
spectacular examples include the
long-distance migrations of monarch
butterflies and salmon so what does this
mean for humans are we also born with
innate information written into our
genomes that helps shape our neural
circuits and ultimately results in
something we know could there be some
knowledge that is unique and intrinsic
to humans as a species by watching this
video you are actually part of an
information sharing network that
connects millions of lifelong learners
across the globe but did you know that
we're also developing a network for
student ideas Ted Ed's student voice
initiative is supporting young people
across the globe in sharing their ideas
and passions with each other and with
the world learn more about this exciting
program and how you can get involved at
IDI ted.com slash clubs
[Music]